something quite en ron ik
about this moment we at the film about
the legal goldmine a in ghana
so and now we still bath oil destruction
both squads at and the obsession of
mankind with
was so shinee what actually and evil
useless
with on so and yes was first  aid has myself
and my name m bunch of standards
you got disco the metal and that man and
by the game that the man or all that
talking about in in my movie so
the the critical journalist in my chest
doesn't fit in surrey views so co2 in
some  way through to the story of my film
but am I the film you will be then yes that
said that tell well so the moment with
all was film I as upcoming filmmakers
how dream about him in and at the get the
chance to be here and this is  al so at the
lantus between two and academy of motion
pictures and arts and science a big fan
of what you guys even come plus so
outflow wonder or or emotional or movies the
mic if climb i al slave make up
step and frank and big fan  or always and and
public deeply  acts to be here and
to be selected s
the best with you the best documentary
international documentary lucy
thank you so much and from your go-to
the people yes dat people there where
necessary for and then en dit great work
for this film  will for the state miss mama
mama the order best numbers or you
from enemy am i will come yet
kelly in so many farmers last
ordered with that is fry mee
supa that's got dark to
challenge to my third is here
train set wish cool you  that you
participate here and tanks alone for reading
the other stories we nou als ik chica
de finca think that somehow this will de
something good work
the teams again
mellow clap hands about and the people in
in kana
how that is minus the community and
add  my lord in surah there is to
be blown to stay take out so many it up
to him and the man there is crocodile onko
with the bank to pick yourself up you this
billy well
there on you of the idea to the video points
can here and  dan estivum ab  ar and then
i was going to the
and film academy band will be back and my
my great colic student claim je wat mi
des mantels nasci the great editing and the
loyal beautiful friend and then exactly man
legal and documentary so you don't need
an added to make sure  you get this
content you fly back to germany
so john as three small toemai plus
tax soundtrack for documentary and
ever was and the as role is easy to get
this small or music flowing for
macadamia nordic orchestral there one
who this kind of thing right and on because
to thank lemmings ran i was a
do dilute where floats succeed so as
bad as they all cold how this the 3d
animation really well done this claudio
gaming and sizes micro the demo them soundmix
mixing but tunic east the color
grading and all access electra'
find mario
damon in the in the editing process and if
orient cuba
your input booth on yo guys your input was
barry crucial and and the post production
of the movie
who's there and he has the salu  d for you
meet
blok a journal is a bossche bol in the
film academy get bang beck
tanks for the concert in thank you did
some and work
om my film die really appreciate my
was an their so do that you here if they
to-night
ben shout  out to my people at fancy jon
ellis was and in a boiler
because go with fer is johannes mosque
inside okay then add to mention the
director at the school
thomas yes de and and then called row to be
a few or the best movies cool and  the
world how is the mos practical approach
to sphinx
finally fill my bag oh hey dude i
maya and thank you for
seeing the potential in this filming so
thomas hobbes the choke but you guys
have seen the film and you have to go with the
postman so filming graces  him out of the
death and some people in a just want to
people quickly get done with all them
would be happy curious full method
heft nou so aan ed kooyman
jan maas na sylvia hasta kristof aan het
hotel card
thank you for your support and finally
my  movie  s and then celie left that you
you that you again much every body
[Applause]